circa resort and casino will make its
debut next wednesday downtown
it's also on the cover of this week's
las vegas weekly magazine brock radke
got an exclusive and extensive look at
the first brand new casino
to open in the valley in years hey brock
how's it going
i'm good how are you good thank you so i
personally can't wait to get a look at
the stadium swim area but
what stood out to you as some of the
most impressive aspects of circa
well you know circa is the first brand
new casino resort to be built in the
downtown area in 40 some years and as
soon as you step foot inside
you can tell it's very different it's
very modern and
just the casino area in general has so
much energy
it's two stories and it's kind of built
around this massive
new sports book so it doesn't matter if
you're actually
in the sports book watching the game on
one of these massive video screens you
can still be
part of the action from all different
points in the casino there's this really
cool
overlook bar looking down into it it's
really
really one of a kind it just looks
massive these huge screens the largest
in all of the town right
yeah those are the biggest the the
screens that stadium swim and
at the sports book are are the biggest
in las vegas uh facilities like these
and brock when you were speaking to the
ceo derrick stevens
um he was saying that circa is the
culmination of everything he's learned
about las vegas where he's lived for the
past 15 years
he says he's found out what visitors and
locals want from a casino resort
and what if some of the what are some of
those things that he says he's learned
well he started off downtown by taking
over the golden gate the oldest casino
in the state then he revamped
fitzgeralds into the d
and then he also created the downtown
las vegas event center which has been
home to
a lot of different kinds of events
including
sports watch parties so he's taken the
things that have worked
and and stayed connected to his
customers at these other venues
and come up use that as inspiration to
come up with ideas
for circa that's fantastic we're going
to be out there live in the various
aspects
of course we've covered the garage mahal
that's pretty impressive as well this
week did you take a look at that
i did i did it's it's kind of silly to
be excited about a parking garage at a
casino but when you realize that
it's really going to be a transportation
hub for the whole downtown area
then you can realize why it's so unique
thank you so much for your time brock we
look forward to
looking more through your article and
we'll see you next time in the meantime
take care
thanks you too all right thanks brock